up the story because a lot of times we need to build the story the right way for people to
latch on and I'm open to working with you guys to building that story together. So my questions
are around just like trying to understand the offering, trying to understand how you work
because the more I can simplify it in my mind the easier I can kind of bring that to my director
and then expand you guys through the team. So don't take my questions as maybe like discounting
what you're putting on the slide. It's just to try to understand like how it works because
we need to tailor this story to more of just the Databricks motion if the goal is to elevate
more engagement and kind of help continue to progress your tiers. So yeah. Okay cool. So industries
that you focus in on, yeah if we can just shift this slide to whatever you've done with Databricks
and the customers there that you can show that'd be awesome but yeah feel free to continue.
Got it. Cool. We'll do that in a few minutes. Jefferson if you could just confirm to me you're
also looking after the financial services customers primarily. Is that understanding correct or
hey you're off the mark completely? Yeah financial services. Good. So for us as well we have you know
decided to focus on a couple of different industries three of them in particular to be more exact.
One of them is financial services the other one is healthcare and life sciences and then this
third automotive, D&D and real estate club into one. So over there we primarily focus on automotive
and digital that is the sort of stuff that we have been doing over there. I'll just give you a
little bit of a rundown. These are a couple of our accelerators which we have created in-house to
you know do the work faster. This is a little bit of a rundown on our existing strengths with Databricks.
So this needs to be updated a little bit. So at this point of time we are carrying about 80 to 90
odd certified associates on Databricks with 60% of the population being data engineers and the
remaining 40% being the machine learning engineer associates. So we carry both of them.
Sorry Dan and Rob. And then in your minds the IBM partnership, the Azure Microsoft
partnership, the AWS partnership. So are you helping migrate like data warehouses over to
Databricks? I see like SAP here at SharePoint. So is it like mostly building up like a
like a GD space is what kind of team is specialized in? Just kind of curious what that looks like.
So Genia I believe has expanded this year to even cover up the AIBI Databricks one and other aspects.
So as of right now we have focused much more on bringing customers onto the data lake itself.
So once the data lake has been created on top of that we create custom solutions for them,
custom agent solutions for them which are able to resolve their particular queries or
particular problems. So bringing everything from your different injection sources that can be
unstructured, structured, semi-structured from SAP SharePoint, your email tracking because a lot
of things from your PDF files, from your Excel files for financial services customers that we
have seen. Bringing all of this information onto a single data lake and on top of that creating
the analytics systems. So it can be done via a custom agent solutions or it can be powered up by
front-ended by Databricks one and then powered by custom applications at the back end.
Does that make sense or no you're off the mark for me?
And then the custom applications are they built on Databricks or where are they built?
Yeah they have it on Databricks.
Okay so you're using like Databricks apps like base, agent breaks?
Not the by default provided Databricks applications because a lot of custom
integration is required for the applications that we end up creating and for the customers the
custom piece is much more relevant rather than taking up what Databricks apps provides out of
the door. For example I'll take the example for one of the recent applications that we created on
Databricks. So that is an APQR acceleration that is for the automotive marketplace that we have
you know gone covered with. Sorry APQR is for the farm manufacturing space. So what they are
looking for is the entire application is it requires a lot of custom connectors.
It is because of the customer requirement. So all of those custom connectors are then being
created or mapped into the Databricks application space wherever it is possible we leverage the
in-house application of in-house connectors but if it's not available we end up creating those
connectors so that we can have a seamless integration. Okay I guess what I'm trying to
I'm trying. Sorry so I think you know with different clients we have had different types
of use cases that we have worked on. So for some I think you know what Ivanshu mentioned
you know it was bringing them on the Databricks data lake house platform depending upon
wherever they needed to ingest data from and then for example for clients like Jump IQ
it was also building an application on top of that data to serve whatever analytics need they
had. So Ivanshu do you want to bring up that site for the Jump IQ thing that might kind of you know
give a solid idea. So I will just bring up this website. Let me know once the screen is visible.
Yeah yeah so Jump IQ yeah yeah I'll give you a quick rundown of what exactly it is. So this
is for an MND advisory firm. Now what happened is all of these data points that you're seeing all
of these small points or bullets or all of these small bullets that you're seeing over here these
are all of the dealers that are currently operating in the US. Now say you have the for example some
in that high network or some individuals would like to identify hey this dealership seems to
perform well and hey these are having good numbers. Would it be financially or would it make a financial
sense for me to go ahead and you know straight out purchase them out of the way. Maybe they are a
local dealer that is operating or maybe they are a national dealer that is operating out of
or a statewide dealer that is operating maybe say in Texas. So for example this one I'm just paying
out a random dealer over here. So this is this they are looking after a Chevy dealership.
What we have done is we have gone forward for this particular customer what we ended up was
hey let's create an entire data lake on the Databricks platform that was step number one that
was completed. Once that was done the customer came back with hey what can we really do so as to
make the entire experience seamless for our end customers. What is the extra information that
can be provided to them. How can we provide it as soon as possible so that they can make the
relevant financial decision to maybe work together with them on a joint partnership or maybe outright
purchase them. So this is a couple of scores that they have created in-house which we assisted
them with hey what is the momentum looking like for them over the last two or three months. What
is their performance so far. What is the environment looking like for them in their particular county.
What is their valuation that is powered by DCG's in-house systems. What is their ranking for this.
How high is this particular dealership being ranked up all of these demographics. This is just a
very quick overview for them and on top of this what happens is once a report request is generated
for this particular customer at the same time the backend system it input or it pulls in data
from the existing data lake at the same time it also leverages the external data sources which
they have specified which they trusted data sources. They have all the coolant information
from these trusted data sources. So at this point we have 20 plus different data sources
all of this information comes in via the streaming platform of Databricks and then it is pumped out
to the customer. Now creating this entire dashboard or creating this entire report and putting it in
front of the customer as accurately as possible and ensuring that hey there's no hallucination that
is happening in the entire report. Those are some of the metrics that we had to take care of and
getting it in front of the customer as soon as possible that was another thing that we had to
really put down our thinking hats on. Got it. So the one thing I'm kind of struggling with here
on this story is how is this driving compute for the Databricks team?
So there are two ways in which the entire compute is being driven up. The entire medallion
architecture it is currently being hosted on the Databricks platform so bronze, silver, gold all
of your three layers are on Databricks. In addition to that all of the backend analytics that
happens that is powered by the Databricks system. So these are the two primary drivers for the entire
data debut consumption as you want to you know as you put it forward for DCG for Databricks.
Got it. So it's some sort of like ETL pipeline and then you're also using the warehouse.
Yeah so because there's data refresh in terms of you know when you get so they're using some
external data sources I think.
from JD Power Associates or other external data sources.
So that is all loaded into the Databricks platform.
And then your team loaded it in.
We established the Connectus.
Okay.
And then is kind of the goal for your team
to get to the more custom application work?
Is that kind of the goal?
Okay.
So in this case, we have a team working with them,
which has worked all the way from the initial,
you know, this was like kind of a startup idea.
So we worked with them all the way
from initial discussions, technical architecture,
you know, help them kind of put together
the whole ETL process, the data platform,
and then building the application on top of it as well.
Got it.
So it's a little bit hard for me to follow it
because this motion kind of geared towards the,
and do you mostly work with the Databricks Hunter teams
or more of the core teams in the current engagement?
So in this case, for example, you know,
we had our own relationship with the client.
So we worked directly with the client.
This was not through a Databricks account executive, right?
We recently are trying to build relationships
with the account executives so that we can co-sell together.
But for example, this was kind of, you know,
totally run by our team directly with the client.
Got it.
And then was the client already on Databricks
or they were in that new?
No, we helped them on board to Databricks.
Similarly for AscentDS, which is in real estate financing,
we worked with them directly and influenced them to,
you know, in that case, they load a lot of data
from county real estate transactional records.
And they use, they consume all that data.
There's a lot of hygiene that needs to be done there
because there could be a parent LLC that, you know,
built one particular real estate, you know, construction
and there could be child entities.
So we do a lot of cleaning on that data
kind of with some manual, you know, interjection if needed
to kind of, you know, match up a couple of things.
And then on top of that,
they run their whole lead generation platform,
lead generation, you know, analytics.
So in that case as well, we started working with them
right from the start in terms of
what are the different types of data they're ingesting?
Where is it coming from?
There are some structured, some unstructured data.
How will that be ingested and loaded at what rate
is that data being refreshed?
You know, how often those loads need to be run.
And so, you know, we had, you know, some relationship
with these clients where they had use cases that, you know,
Databricks was the right platform to be used.
And now we're trying to kind of, you know,
establish relationships with account executives
so that we can start to co-sell.
You know, we have built strong capabilities in the area
and how can we kind of, you know, work together
to scale both of us further?
Yeah.
Do you know what our activated logo motion is?
No.
So, kind of just when talking about it
and talking through your programs,
this is what I would recommend kind of framing up the story.
Yeah.
So thanks for the partnership so far
on growing some of these accounts.
So what an activated logo for us is getting an account
to spend at least $1,000 a month, two months in a row,
or signing a Databricks committed baseline contract.
So those are the two ways that...
Which is 15K, I believe.
Yeah, those are the two ways that AEs get compensated.
So that's kind of the story we have to tell
when bringing up your slides is,
how do you help account executives activate customers?
So if we wanna use existing stories,
whether from a sense, DS or whatnot,
like I would encourage you to review
what that engagement looked like,
work with the existing AE to understand
how much consumption that drove.
What drove that consumption?
And then focus less on maybe the end application build first.
And then, right, this is how Short Hills AI
helps you activate accounts and customers, right?
That's how we can quickly just understand what you do
and then start introducing the customers.
In terms of the end state use cases,
probably a little bit less important at this time.
Like if it's building a data application,
if that's where your bread and butter is,
like I'll keep that in my back of mind.
But I guess based on the customer engagements,
like where do you feel like really helped
grow these customers on Databricks?
So that's probably a question back to you guys.
Yeah, Fesan, two things for you.
The thing that you mentioned about,
hey, what is this really,
what is this stuff that we're doing?
Is this really driving the end goal for you?
Is this helping you meet your metrics?
That is, I believe, one important thing for you.
So the amount of consumption that the solutions
that we create, it could allow you to meet
or exceed your targets within the month itself.
Let me just put it that way.
I cannot tell about the exact consumption that...
Yeah, sorry, it's okay.
You don't have to sell me on it.
That needs to be on the slide,
if you want to be successful is what I'm trying to say.
So these are just feedback points.
I know the information is maybe loose right now, that's okay.
But I'm just trying to help you sell this story
because the slide as it stands now is a little bit confusing
on why I would choose you guys versus another partner
because it's more focused on you.
And you just have a slide that's more focused on
being an extension of the Databricks AE team
and how we activate customers.
And you don't have to sell me on this now.
I know you can do this work,
but we're talking to get some feedback because...
Definitely.
I can't visualize it today
based on what I've seen and what I've heard.
Got it.
So if we can reframe that story
and then come back together with some different slides,
focus on the activation piece versus...
And then the accolades that you have around IBM and video,
like how does that tie back into like growing consumption
and the customer base at Databricks?
It's like, are you migrating from those?
Or do you have expertise there?
So you're helping with warehouse migrations
or do you have expertise there?
So you're like building models on Databricks.
So like that kind of needs to be a story to help grow the...
That's valuable feedback.
So that it's clear to you where can we quickly go after together.
Yeah, exactly.
And if it's financial services,
like what are the use cases that resonate well that you've solved?
And we even have this.
I'll just share this with you.
Yeah.
And this is what I like to do with other partners as well.
If you want to send me your deck,
I'll plug it into our internal Glean,
map it back to our partner cell motion
and also our activated cells motion,
and then Glean will spit out some feedback
on how to better resonate with the AE team
if you want me to do that.
I appreciate that.
So like...
I don't know if our partner rep has shared this with you,
but we need to map back what you do
to like launching these use cases quickly
in these three themes.
Okay.
You don't need to sell me on that.
You've done this right now,
but just take that as an ask back
and kind of tweak those slides the tailor towards
like launching use cases within this vertical
if you've done it before.
And then also the activated logo motion.
So that would be my recommendation
because it's to make sure this partnership is successful.
Okay. Got it.
That helped.
So this is drive growth, protect the firm,
operate more efficiently.
Okay.
So these are the different...
And this is what every vertical is thinking about.
Like from capital markets to insurance,
these are the three themes, right?
Drive growth, protect the firm
and operate more efficiently.
So we can map out like whatever your brick builder
solutions are to one of these themes.
Like I can...
Here's a story I want to tell, right?
Short Hills can help us activate new logos
for any of the banking and insurance drive growth initiatives
around customer 360, blah, blah, blah.
How they do it is they help customers and guests
from XYZ data sources that are not generalized
but industry specific.
They use Lakeflow Connect,
they use Databricks SQL Warehouse,
and then they use Asian bricks for PDF parsing to do blah, blah, blah.
That's the story that needs to be told here for it to actually resonate.
Got it. That helps out.
Or else be a very clean story of like,
we will be an extension of your team.
This is a six to 12-week no-cost program
that you can leverage us for to help with data ingestion quickly.
We'll bring together a zero-dollar blank SOW.
We'll jump into the accounts,
do whatever you need us to do,
and then we'll earn the right to win the rest of the business,
which is the application build.
Those are the story that's clean and easy for us to just reference.
That'd be my recommendation if we were to go forward with this.
Yeah, we can work on that.
Awesome. Awesome team.
Any other questions with thinking about just partnering in general,
like what they use care about, things like that?
We would love to also see which accounts you are covering
and act as your extension.
I'll send you that list for sure as I follow on.
Yeah. Sounds good. We'll work on redesigning the deck.
Manchu can share the current deck with you.
Whatever feedback you want to send,
that will be helpful in customizing it further.
Awesome. Thanks team. I got a job. Have a good one.
Okay. Thank you, Jefferson. Talk to you soon again. Bye.
Bye.